في اسرائيل قالت وسائل اعلام ان رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ناشد وزراءه عدم
الخروج من الحكومه مشيرا الى ان ذلك سيضر
بوحده الصف الاسرائيلي كانت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه قد نقلت تسريبات عما جرى خلال
اجتماع مجلس الوزراء المصغر للشؤون
الامنيه والسياسيه التي امتدت حتى ساعه
متاخره من ليله امس وقالت ان نتنياهو حسم
السجال بين وزرائه في الجلسه بتاكيد ما
وصفها بثلاثه شروط لا تستطيع اسرائيل
القبول بها من اجل ابرام صفقه تبادل جديده
للاسرى مع حماس واوضح نتنياهو ان حكومته
لا تستطيع السماح بوقف اطلاق النار وانهاء
الحرب ولا توافق على الافراج عن الاف
الاسرى الفلسطينيين كما انها لن تسمح
بخروج الجيش من قطاع
غزه ونقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن مصادر
مطلعه ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتانياهو التقى في مكتبه بمدير مكتبه
السابق ثان اشيل وناقش امكانيه تحييد
المعارضه من اليمين فيما يتعلق بصفقه
الرهائن التي بدات
تتبلور من جهتها نقلت صحيفه ارتس عن مسؤول
في حزب المعسكر الذي يقوله بين جانس قوله
ان الحزب سينسحب من حكومه الطوارئ
الاسرائيليه اذا توصل الى انطباعا بان
نتنياهو يرفض صفقه تبادل الاسرى لاعتبارات
سياسيه او اذا اعلن نتنياهو عن حكم عسكري
في
غزه